[Music]
this is a journey into the middle east
we're all dancing in here las vegas has
a new music experience at the virgin
hotels las vegas and las vegas native
mecca starts her new residency on
september 17th he joins us now thank you
for being here thank you for having me
how does this feel we've got a brand new
residency brand new hotel how does that
feel it's surreal honestly it's supe
it's surreal you're gonna be doing your
home town too yes i'm from las vegas
born and raised so i'm definitely
representing
vegas how would you how would you
someone's uh checking out for the first
time how would you describe the new show
i would describe top 40
good music connection
definitely
unique unique arrangements so i don't
like to do anything like the record i
like to kind of swing out
vibe
you put your own spin on it the mecha
spin on everything that you do yes and
you were on american idol at one point
yes how was yours american idol for you
and how was that process um i was in
season five and it was an incredible
learning experience for me i learned so
much about performing and
uh just so much about myself as an
artist
when you're out there would you be
nervous in front of judges were you
nervous at all during that process no no
so in my personal life i'm i'm
definitely shy but when i'm on stage
when i'm on and performing it's a
completely different person and i love
the fact that you're las vegas native
where did you go to high school las
vegas academy and all your friends
are your friends and family all lined up
to come see the new show yes they
they're very excited and i'm actually
currently playing there uh
tonight uh from nine to one okay okay
awesome so nine o'clock is the shag room
inside there yes officially it starts in
september okay so but tonight we can go
see you tonight kind of get a sneak peek
at the performance absolutely what's the
shag room what was that venue like uh
the chagroom is a very
it's like shagadelic vibe
it's a beautiful venue inside the virgin
and
it's just
super shackadelic i love it yeah you are
so awesome thank you so much for joining
us can't wait to see the show thank you
so much for having me vegas girl doing
good things rocky we'll send it over to
you becca i need